We are so glad that you are back.
Yes.
You've been with us since the beginning, as I've said.
Please take it away and tell our next story, Zainab.
Okay, next up.
Okay, so we've gotta look to our elders
for that wise advice on how to live a good life.
And the "New York Post" reports
that a British great-grandmother named Lily Bullen
just turned 102 years old,
and she says that her secret is tequila.
Yes, she does.
Yes, ma'am
(audience clapping)
Yes, yes.
So she celebrated with shots this year
and she says that tequila has helped her love her life,
and she also credits pizza.
Who doesn't love pizza, right?
I love this woman.
I always say, happy hour equals happy life.
And it's not about getting drunk,
but it's about like having fun, you know?
And to think that like that's the secret
is just to loosen up a little bit,
have a slice of pizza, girl, sign me up.
Also, like sometimes I'll watch like interviews with J.Lo,
who I'm obsessed with,
been begging her to please,
please come with your presence on the show.
But I wanna say to you, I'm afraid sometimes.
Like I can tell she drinks water and works out,
and like has that diligent lifestyle.
And I'm like, "Oh my god,
I am like a dumpster fire next to this woman."
Like I am just like, ah, ugh, arr!
But, you know, there's the people
who like live the healthiest, cleanest lives,
and then they get hit by a bus,
you know?
Uh-huh.
And then, there's the people who have like,
"I've been smoking for 109 years old
and I'm still here," you know?
So I think the key is what you said, Ross, it's joy.
However you get it.
However you find it.
Yeah, it's laughter and joy is what keeps you alive.
(audience clapping)
I agree.
Agreed.
Yeah.
But, what about this story?
We've got a new wedding trend
you might not have heard of yet.
Well, you know, monogamy, right?
Well, what's the solo version, right, you know.
What's the solo version of monogamy?
They call it sologamy,
which means a wedding for one.
"Insider" reports more brides are choosing to go it alone,
and they're getting married to themselves.
Some women are doing it with just a wedding ring.
Others are adding the dress, a full guest list,
throwing in a ceremony with a reception and appetizers.
Sologamists say it's an act of commitment to yourself
to loving yourself and having more self-compassion.
I saw Drew sipping her tea over there.
Thoughts?
(sighs) I mean, I'm single for six years.
I love like my solo life.
Uh-huh.
But I don't really get the monogamy
with the marriage and sologamy.
Like it sounds like sausage or--
No, let's just, no, no, no.
It's too much, it's too much!
Really?
Yeah.
First of all, now 'cause you love yourself,
I have to spend $300 on a bridesmaid's dress?
Yeah, mhmm, mhmm.
No.
Yeah.
But this is what happens.
I knew it was gonna get outta hand.
The moment we started celebrating birthdays for months,
I was like, "We're gonna start marrying ourselves."
Yeah, (laughs) and how does it even work?
Are you like, "I do."
"Oh, I do too."
"Oh, this is great."
Or like, do you wear a wedding ring,
and if someone like wants to date you,
you're like, "I'm taken with me."
You know, there's these like grand weddings?
There's like a scale of what people can afford.
So it's like, yeah, you can have this like
grand, cute wedding.
But then what about the person that like doesn't have much?
Do they just go down to like the justice of the peace?
Like, "It's just me."
You know, that all said,
sometimes I give myself the test in my own brain
of like someone who was really empowered by this.
Like I had never thought of a divorce registry
until we talked about it on the show,
because it was a news story.
And I thought, "Oh, God, all the people
that like lose so much stuff
and their friends wanna help, but they don't know how,
and this could be a whole new movement."
You know what?
To each their own.
If people wanna do this, you know,
hey, why not?
Love yourself.
Well, no, how about this?
If you wanna take care of yourself, go on vacation.
Don't marry yourself, girl.
What are you doing?
(audience clapping)
You know, I think like the less we judge each other,
the better, that's all I'm gonna say.
Do you, or I mean.
Oh, hey! (laughs)
Literally, do you!
(upbeat music)